[Música]
hola soy natalia cabrera y les doy la
bienvenida aquí a américa el espacio de
france 24 para revisar en profundidad
las noticias e historias de nuestro
continente y esto es lo que veremos hoy
en el super domingo electoral en
suramérica regionales en venezuela y
presidenciales en chile les contamos de
la mano de nuestros corresponsales en
santiago quienes josé antonio kast que
han sido comparado con líderes ultra
conservadores como el presidente de
brasil ya ir bolsonaro o el ex
mandatario de estadounidense donald sort
y desde caracas veremos también con
nuestro equipo periodístico cómo la
oposición intentó revertir su propio
boicot convocado en pasados comicios
ante la desconfianza en las autoridades
electorales vinculadas al chavismo y por
primera vez desde 2016 los jefes de
estado y de gobierno de norteamérica se
reunieron jostin trudeau joe biden y
andrés manuel lópez obrador discutieron
temas clave como la emigración y la
economía les ampliamos en segundos
y empezamos en chile que pasa unas
semanas turbulentas la campaña de la
presidencia estuvo marcada por la
polarización y un cerco al presidente
sebastián piñera tras las revelaciones
de los papeles de pandora según las
cuales piñera habría cometido
irregularidades en la venta de un
proyecto minero en su primer mandato en
2010 piñera sobrevivió el voto en el
senado para removerlo del cargo pero al
margen de este juicio político la
fiscalía abrió una investigación contra
él pese a la suspensión de un proceso
anterior en 2017 el rechazo del senado
llegó tan sólo cinco días antes de las
elecciones
en medio de la polarización para estos
comicios la candidatura del
ultraconservador josé antonio kast vio
un aumento dramático en la intención de
voto como explicar la popularidad de
este abogado de 55 años que elogió la
herencia económica del dictador augusto
pinochet nos lo explica desde santiago
el corresponsal de nuestra cadena
hermana en francés toma niccoló
para decir
estamos apoyando a josé antonio casa
para que eso sea por locas
[Música]
y la afluencia es decepcionante pero el
entusiasmo está ahí enfrente
socialcristiano la familia política de
josé antonio kast rechaza la etiqueta de
extrema derecha la izquierda radical se
encargó de instalar la idea de que él
representaba una derecha extrema
se nos ubica con visos fascistas pero
realmente lo que propone josé antonio es
lo que podríamos llamar en este sentido
común lo que aspira a las personas no
excepto en familia
amor a la patria
tranquila paz social y orden pero josé
antonio kast se ha convertido en la cara
de una derecha chilena desinhibida que
seduce con un discurso conservador sobre
migración e inseguridad una de las cosas
que más rescato de jose antonio kast que
le falta mucho a los jóvenes es siempre
sí la verdad sin miedo la perseverancia
por lograr lo que él quiere creo que los
jóvenes en general en chile están en una
estación muy cómoda y les incomoda
justamente que le digan la verdad hijos
antonio no tiene miedo y siempre la
verdad por delante el discurso de josé
antonio kast se radicalizó tras las
manifestaciones que algunas veces
terminaban en violencia de 2.019
lideradas por la izquierda progresista
kast logró ampliar su base entre los
indecisos
inicialmente no era mi candidato
pero hoy en día si lo es dado a lo que
está atravesando mi país
nos da seguridad estabilidad
y creo que es el único que va a tener la
mano firme para eliminar el narcotráfico
y la delincuencia a pesar de que ha
apuntado a atender estos problemas casi
ha repetido mentiras como que en los
países donde hay aborto libre la tasa de
maternidad es mucho más alta o que
durante la dictadura de augusto pinochet
no se encerró opositores
[Aplausos]
y hablemos ahora de los comicios
regionales en venezuela donde el
principal reto de la oposición era
recuperar la confianza en el voto luego
de años de llamados a la abstención
debido a la desconfianza en el consejo
nacional electoral cuyos integrantes
fueron durante años nombrados por el
chavismo esta vez por primera vez en 15
años hay observadores de la unión
europea y en mayo gracias a la presión
internacional se incluyó a dos
integrantes de la oposición entre ellos
veamos el informe de nuestra
corresponsal en caracas daniela zambrano
venía por acá para invitarte a votar
habla con tu familia josé cardoso no es
político ni activista es un ciudadano
jubilado residente de esta parroquia del
oeste de la capital que inició una
campaña para convencer a sus vecinos de
ir a votar por la oposición ahora hay
una mesa de diálogo de entendimiento
entre la oposición y el gobierno que se
respete la condición electoral y estoy
creyendo en ese diálogo tras dos años en
el exilio el dirigente opositor tomás
guanipa busca una alcaldía en caracas
convenciendo puerta a puerta a los
votantes de que el momento de recuperar
espacios políticos es ahora no estamos
en unas elecciones libres aún tenemos
que luchar mucho más por condiciones
libres para que podamos elegir un nuevo
gobierno de lejos luisa observa a los
políticos pasar anhelo un cambio en 22
años gobernados por el chavismo nunca le
han atendido sus necesidades trabaja ya
decantada mi ser le encantaba tanta
burla
el reto que enfrenta la oposición es
revertir la idea de abstención que
durante los últimos tres comicios
infundió en sus seguidores entre otras
razones por desconfianza en el consejo
nacional electoral la analista luis
vicente león explica que no fue la mejor
estrategia si tú no cambias estabas
condenado a que surgiera otro grupo
opositor y otro liderazgo sourcing que
se tomara completo la lucha por el
cambio en venezuela cambiar el discurso
no es suficiente hay quienes como omar
angélica los venció la excepción de una
oposición que no ha logrado ponerse de
acuerdo en la estrategia para cambiar de
gobierno no pienso votar porque estoy
muy desilusionada de la oposición
después de una larga jornada josé
regresa a su rutina convencido de que el
voto es la vía especialmente por
tratarse de unos comicios que por
primera vez en 15 años cuentan con la
presencia de la misión de observación
internacional de la unión europea y los
tres jefes de estado y de gobierno de
norteamérica se reunieron esta semana
por primera vez desde 2016 andrés manuel
lópez obrador pidió a joe biden ya
justin trudeau que acepten a los
migrantes para hacer frente a la escasez
de personal que enfrenta a norteamérica
y porque los necesitan para mantener el
crecimiento económico frente a la
influencia china para lo que además
propuso diseñar un plan para reducir la
dependencia de las importaciones
asiáticas y mientras ellos se reunían y
discutían estos temas clave para el
norte del continente una nueva caravana
de emigrantes salió desde la ciudad
mexicana de tapachula hacia estados
unidos mientras los migrantes denuncian
que las autoridades mexicanas les están
ofreciendo permisos de residencia a
cambio de que desistan de sus planes de
ir a la unión americana
y hablemos de cuba para revisar otras
noticias de las américas esta semana
llegó a madrid tras denunciar asedios
por parte de las autoridades cubanas el
líder opositor júnior garcía fundador de
la organización archipiélago que convocó
a las históricas manifestaciones
antigubernamentales de julio y las del
15 de noviembre que no pudieron
celebrarse debido a que el régimen de
miguel díaz canel no impidió no se trata
de un gobierno se trata de una dictadura
y si alguien tiene problemas con esa
palabra pues bueno también está la
palabra tiranía pero en un lugar donde
las personas son tratadas como gusanos
porque así nos llaman donde las personas
son aplastadas amenazados no se puede
hablar de que haya ningún tipo de
democracia dejemos de usar adjetivos la
democracia existe o no
tiempo libia tras semanas de protestas y
enfrentamientos entre manifestantes y la
policía que dejaron al menos un muerto
el presidente luís arte derogó la
bautizada como ley de ganancias ilícitas
y lucha contra el terrorismo que imponía
controles y sanciones para evitar que el
dinero del tráfico de drogas
a través de transacciones informales
decisión de abrogar la ley en 386
objeto del primero allanar el camino
para que no exista el mayor pretexto
y seguiré luchando para y maltratando
para seguir paralizando nuestra economía
y honduras es uno de eeuu y guatemala y
ahora son tres los países de américa que
reconocen a jerusalén como la capital de
israel luego de que en 2017 el entonces
presidente de eeuu donald trump hiciera
lo mismo en respuesta a esta semana se
inauguró la sede diplomática israelí en
tegucigalpa el presidente hondureño
habló con nuestra corresponsal y kenia
torres sobre las tensiones que esto
puede generar con el pueblo palestino
palestina recuerdo nosotros tuvimos
siempre una política
honduras reconoció en los todos pueblos
tienen el derecho y la comunidad
internacional el deber de buscar paz y
tranquilidad así como nación mantiene el
golfo nos toca hacer del cuerpo una zona
de paz y de desarrollo lo mismo deseamos
para el medio y vamos a revisar nuestra
cifra de la semana
34.9 millones de dólares una pintura de
frida kahlo fue vendida por ese valor
una cifra récord para un artista
latinoamericano el autorretrato de la
mexicana fue realizado en 1949 y se
llama diego y yo y en ella se ve la cara
de frida con la cara de su esposo diego
ribera en la frente
la obra es ahora la máscara de un
latinoamericano jamás vendida en una
subasta el recorte anterior era el mismo
diego ribera pero los rivales se vendió
por menos de un tercio de este precio
hace tres años
fue una subasta que todos sabían iba a
cautivar a los entusiastas del arte en
el mundo
el lote número 12 es el siguiente y
estamos por supuesto muy emocionados de
ofrecer este autorretrato de frida kahlo
de 1949 diego y yo el último
autorretrato íntegramente realizado por
la artista antes de su muerte en 1954 la
obra muestra lágrimas en los ojos de
kahlo y su esposo diego ribera cubriendo
parte de su cabeza simboliza su
tormentosa relación la pareja estuvo
casada durante casi 25 años en un
apasionado pero difícil matrimonio la
pintura mide solamente 30 x 22.4
centímetros y es la primera vez que hace
una aparición en el mercado del arte en
más de 30 años en cuanto empezó la
subasta empezó la carrera
y apenas un minuto después taiwán
belinda por 31 millones de dólares
última oportunidad la oferta de anna por
31 millones de dólares
el costo total de casi 35 millones de
dólares incluidos los impuestos hace de
esta la obra de arte más cara de un
artista latinoamericano jamás vendida
gracias por acompañarme en esta emisión
de aquí américa recuerden que pueden
seguirme en redes sociales en la
dirección que ven en sus pantallas en la
producción estuvo joan y agudelo sigan
viendo más en france 24 y france24
puntocom
[Música]